evacuations of two besieged cities in
ukraine are being delayed amid reports
that russia is violating a temporary
ceasefire earlier moscow announced a
five-hour halt to its attacks on
volnovah and the strategic port city of
mariupol in southeastern ukraine to
allow civilians access to a safe
humanitarian corridor but officials in
mario paul say russian forces are not
observing the ceasefire along the entire
route the city is without water and
power and is running out of food after
being surrounded by russian forces
after days of relentless shelling in the
keyport city of mariopol russia has said
it will stop firing and allow civilians
to flee
president zielenski confirmed the
ceasefire also applies here in the
nearby city of volnovka which has also
seen heavy fighting
humanitarian corridors will work today
in mariupol
to save people especially women children
elderly people
to provide those who will stay with food
and medicine
our aid is on the way all who need help
must have an opportunity to leave
but the two cities are far from the only
areas devastated by russian bombardment
zielenski has been pleading with nato to
set up a no-fly zone to stop russian
airstrikes like this one outside kiev
but nato has ruled that out an all-out
war in europe that's what the alliance
wants to avoid according to u.s
secretary of state andy blinken
the only way to actually implement
something like a no-fly zone
is to send nato planes into ukrainian
airspace and to shoot down russian
planes and that
uh could lead to a full-fledged war
in europe president biden has been clear
that we
are not going to get into a war with
russia
as fighting enters a tenth day the
situation in ukraine becomes more and
more desperate
casualties are mounting and over one
million people have now fled the country
there are reports of severe food and
water shortages in some cities including
kiev
in the occupied city of moletopol to the
south russian soldiers hand out food
it's the second city in ukraine said to
be under the invaders control after
hassan
with russian forces on the move across
the country
and nato ruling out intervention
people here are preparing for a long
bitter battle ahead
dw correspondent matthias bullinger
joins us from kiev matthias i wanted to
start by asking you about that
humanitarian situation in mariupol and
surrounds
mariupol's authorities deputy mayor
saying the humanitarian ceasefire is not
being upheld what more can you tell us
well we've heard that the situation is
really dire in mariupol we've seen that
we've seen news from from the past few
days
some pictures have made it out that much
of the city has been damaged or
destroyed and people have been hiding in
shelters for days there's no water and
no electricity there has been no water
or no electricity for some days now and
it's it seems to be very very bad there
um the city is surrounded by the russian
forces from three sides from the from
from from the land side and uh from the
seaside uh there's the russian navy so
it's very dire we have there was uh
a corridor was planned to evacuate
people from there and we've heard that
it has not happened that the russian
forces have continued to shell the city
that's what the mayor has said we have
no information of course no no no real
time information of what's going on in
the city
now you've just arrived back in kiev
what's the situation where you are today
well you can see this maidan which is
usually a quite a busy uh square and the
center of kiev is almost completely
empty there are a few other journalists
and then
some some people are crossing the square
maybe to get home or
or so but very few people on the street
the city feels almost empty many people
have left the city um so far it's quiet
we've heard from people here that they
have been hiding in bombshelters for
quite some time there have also been
bombs coming down on the city in the
past few days at the moment it's very
calm eerily quiet eerily empty
is there a big difference from when you
were there a few days ago into intense
in the terms of that feeling that sense
of what's going on there
it has had started already a few days
ago when we left the city uh uh and uh
we heard frequent uh bomb alarms there
and this this area was also empty the
difference is that we see a lot more
military now roadblocks etc etc so uh
the feeling is definitely that it has
gotten worse or more tense here that's
for sure
all right matthias thank you for that
update matthias berlinga and kiev
maria siroshenko is a resident of that
besieged city mario poll that we've been
speaking about she's now safely
evacuated and in the western city of la
vie she joins me now maria thanks so
much for joining us and i'm very happy
to hear that you've been evacuated from
mario poll your family however is still
there what are they telling you what are
you hearing about the situation there
hi yes the situation is marupal is uh
getting worse and um i didn't hear from
my relatives from my family from my
grandma my friends for the fifth day in
a row uh they don't have any
electricity they don't have heat and
there is no mobile connection in the
city for the fifth days
and uh there is a lack of food and water
in the city and uh right now we we are
trying constantly to reach them we are
trying to call them but still no luck
and this morning there was some news
that the vacation might start right now
the official news however since the
russians didn't seize the fire uh the
citizens of marupo still can't go out of
the city because it's not safe so i'm
really worried about my family and
everyone in mariota so a full five days
that you haven't been able to contact
any of your friends or family in the
city
yeah that's great
well tell us a little bit about your
evacuation when you left and the journey
there tel aviv
yep um basically i i left kiev because i
was in kiev when the war started i was
there for two days and two nights we
were hiding in a basement and we were
hearing all the attacks going there but
after two days right before the bridge
was basically exploded we managed to
leave kiev i drove with my car and with
my
uh with my friends and right now i'm if
it took maybe a few days of the journey
because there were some
uh shortages of gas uh during our course
and uh uh right now we are safe and we
leave
so what's your next step then are you
planning to stay there in la viv until
you hear word from your family or are
you looking to
evacuate ukraine all together
well it's a hard question because right
now what i can do i try to help here i
try to volunteer a bit and we have some
people here who want to buy medicines
and especially uh the medicines which is
really difficult to find in ukraine and
leave so we are trying to get them from
poland and this is maybe the main
mission and also um we're trying to find
some humanitarian help and to
provide it to kiev and to other cities
which um which are not closed or
surrounded like mariupol because uh
currently there is no way to provide
humanitarian help to marijuana because
the city is surrounded
among your friends and family all the
people that you speak to there even
strangers on the street is there still
that sense of defiance that we've been
hearing about and determination
absolutely people are sure that we will
win people uh want to defend their
country and i'm 100 percent sure that we
will not stop fighting
so i'm in love the atmosphere is really
strong and people
are looking for
the equipment to our soldiers
and uh
we want to do everything that we can to
help our army and our people
maria syriachenko i wish you all the
very best stay safe and thank you very
much for speaking to us today
thank you
people around the world have been
rallying in support of ukraine president
vladimir zelinski has spoken to crowds
of demonstrators via video link urging
them to keep showing solidarity tens of
thousands gathered in prague the czech
capital to voice their outrage against
the war and in georgia a country that
has a troubled relationship with russia
people filled the streets of the capital
tbilisi many waving ukrainian flags
there were further shows of support in
other major european cities though
demonstrations have been banned in
russia
you